epstein's still in the noose yeah we're
not tired yet
yes we're kind of tired we are kind of
cause it's not really in the news
yeah that's the part that bugs me yeah
is that like it's making headlines on
like some newspapers like nobody really
cares i don't hear anyone talking about
it so this guy john luke brunell
was one of epstein's pimps so he was a
french model agent that he would supply
girls to epstein and like notorious
creed rapist scumbag like he had like
rape charges in the 80s when like you
were allowed to do it when yeah yeah
like it was that bad bro if you raped in
the 80s bro
that's egregious i've seen mad men like
what's that show mad men you haven't
seen it i haven't seen it you acted like
you saw it but you read the wikipedia
page i did it and you just made up a
title for it don't let me repeat it and
i had them read it to me no i didn't
that was cute
that was cute and depending on where
this section goes in the episode it
might be funny or might be completely
controlled
but then they'll understand later yes
they will yes they will okay so i did i
did see that and back in the day you
could just do whatever whatever you want
because politics was very strange yes it
was and that's when he was getting
caught up then so that's how you know
he's a monster so if you were raping
back then then it was 100 confirmed
raping yeah okay and you were just
taking it too far
is that what you're trying to say it
seems like what you're trying to say is
like you were allowed to rape so he went
like above and beyond with his rape i
guess any raping is wrong yeah but at
the time people looked at it different
did that he guess
i mean i wasn't there you weren't there
but do you need to be there to know if a
rape is a right mark i know that rave is
a rape okay i'm just making sure because
it seems like you're a little bit
uncertain right now as you describe this
no why are you on the fence dude what do
you mean i think you should put your
foot down dude okay fine rape is bad
good
no bad
bad bad yes oh that was good you almost
flipped it on me right there i was
saying you're good for believing that
but then you made it look like i was
saying rape is good well you just said
good all right i did say it and i
pointed my opinion rape is good bro you
guys need to chill out right now you got
a chair caught in a triangle
well everybody's in a triangle right now
and we need to chill to [ __ ]
rape is
bad
okay he's a piece of [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
he was actually in jail this time for
raping a minor yeah and you know what's
really funny is
rape of a minor above 15 is a the name
of the charge
in france
and it's just like can it just be rape
in a minor france
why do we have to distinguish like
but their age of consent is much lower
oh
so like 15 might be legal because
they're so [ __ ] disgusting over there
so it's like that is allowed
they're like yeah the age of consent is
there she's still a minor i guess
ah
but you can't rape her anymore but
shouldn't they look at this law and be
like oh maybe we should adjust some
things
yeah i mean when you're the attorney
being like well how old was she like
that's probably like when you should ask
yourself well she wasn't a miner
like if you even have to say that about
a 15 year old yeah i think that's a
little bit of a problem yeah okay so we
have to work on the french judicial
system
doesn't make you a rapist it does too
yeah it does no it doesn't yeah come on
bro come on bro try speaking
try speaking it what speak some french
see if you don't feel rapey a little bit
dude belle wrap it or mark
whoa
whoa
huh
yeah
that's gonna happen bro why why would i
be in prison though well anyway
because you love your favorite pasta
jesus christ he's getting horny dude i
see his [ __ ] pants rising oh this is
different dude you're not doing it no no
no no no no no no no no no no no
miles can you make sure we start the
episode with this
okay this is this is serious yeah so
he's in the prison yes okay
he's in the prison yeah hangs himself
allegedly allegedly they don't have the
cameras on again they happen to be off
happen to be off this is like his third
suicide attempt and he was supposed to
be in a cell that doesn't have like that
has rounded corners okay and has like
terrible bed sheets and [ __ ] ah
and uh for some reason he wasn't in
there still had a bed sheet that you
could hang yourself with now so here's
my question
does this make epstein doing it to
himself more believable
i'll throw it out there but like
and is maybe the the deal that's been
given to an epstein where it's base and
this john luke guy and anybody else
involved is the deal essentially like
look it's over it's done you're going to
go to jail for the rest of your life
if you want to do something about that
hmm
what we can do is just look the other
way while you're in the cell alone and
there happens to be these sheets
you see so instead of like someone went
in there and like choked the [ __ ] out of
him
they basically said it's over guys
but since you have so much incriminating
evidence
what we're going to allow you to do is
take your own life before you live the
worst possible life ever in jail
interesting
crazy to say yeah i don't know yeah not
crazy but then why not gizzling
that's the thing maybe they offered her
and she's like
i ain't doing it and they're like okay
[ __ ]
well you'll see you'll see
apparently he was willing to work with
prosecutors oh [ __ ] that was the other
thing is that like he had made some type
of like verbal commitment like met with
prosecutors once and was like
yeah i'll
i'm down to cooperate
allegedly it's from one of the an
article that i made okay so here's
another conversation
does this happen so much that it just
becomes normalized and then we basically
live in russia
where like life goes on in russia like
they play video games they go out to
night clubs they party they have like
pool tournaments they go bowling with
their friends they just have regular and
then they find out that somebody talks
some [ __ ] about putin and then he just
dies randomly and then they're just like
oh yeah kind of that's what happens
but the reality is is like talking about
putin isn't that important to many
people's lives yeah they're working at
domino's they're doing delivery they're
like i don't need to fight back against
putin yeah right like what i need to do
is just deliver these [ __ ] pizzas so
i can play pool with my boys on the
weekend i can watch the soccer game and
do whatever the [ __ ] i want and i wonder
if they just inundate us with all these
like conspiratorial you know deaths and
suicides that we just start going oh
that's just kind of how life is
these people were involved with the
government these people did this [ __ ]
up [ __ ] and they get taken out when they
do it and instead of us being angry
every single time we just start going
i guess you're not shouldn't get
involved in that because that's the fate
yeah i mean that's just what people are
doing right like i've seen so many
people that just like read post the
story they're just like well weird how
this always happens yeah they make
t-shirts yeah thinking that they're like
fighting a good fight but no they're not
they're actually the t-shirt normalizes
what is the fight though what do you do
yeah if you don't know who the bad guys
are it's hard to and and if you don't
have any reason to think to like
like i don't know who's going into
french
like think about also like the global
connectiveness you have to have in order
to do this like epstein's killed where
is he like brooklyn or something yep so
like or no manhattan right yeah so like
you have to be in conjunction with like
us government new york government
someone has to go in and kill him and
then you also have to be in conjunction
with like french officials french
government this guy's in a different
country
in jail in paris like
so it's like i don't even know who that
person is it almost leads more credence
to like you were saying before epstein
killing himself
and like jean-luc killing himself
because the organization to pull this
off would be reduced maybe it's possible
maybe they're all connected through this
like pedophilia web which i've heard
people float the idea before but yeah
i don't know or or maybe like you said
they just let it happen it doesn't take
that much organization to pull that off
you just have to have some money and pay
the right person yeah and and connection
and like um pay a couple guards so look
the other way and boom yeah but that's
going to come back to you
that's the thing about the conspiracy
[ __ ] that like the easiest way to
discredit the conspiracy is how do you
keep this secret yeah right it's with
every single one it's like okay if 911
was an inside job like
who's keeping the secret because you
need at least 10 people to organize this
right
minimum
you need five people
two people
like this is maybe the secret's not kept
though maybe like people some people
come out and say it and then other
people are like oh i'm not gonna put my
name on it
because if they're gonna kill someone
for
being in jail for like procuring women
for epstein yeah if i blow the whistle
on it and
it implicates me the bigger person
because the only people who know about
it are the people who are involved so
you either have to stand on it and put
your name out there and then risk
getting murked
or risk getting called like a conspiracy
theorist and like getting your whole
career discredited or you leak it
anonymously and then it's just another
conspiracy so it's basically mutually
assured destruction you only bring
people in that are responsible
and
and they basically don't want people to
know that they took down the towers or
were part of this pedophile ring or
whatever or you bring people in that are
like complicit or compromised in some
way
ah okay so it's like if you don't do
this we're going to tell everybody what
you did do
yeah like if you're going to be in our
network where we talk about
like for curing women for epstein and
flying chicks around the world
you have to be compromised in some way
yo if you want to be president or if you
want to be some sort of like political
figure right uh
do you do some [ __ ] up [ __ ] on purpose
and cover it up
to let the powers it be
know that they can compromise you
you just do it for him like you do like
you basically do some foul [ __ ] cover it
up and then it's like a wink
it's like yo this is what i did y'all
don't even got to make me do it i did it
you guys know if you meet with someone
and they're like so you want to be
present you're like hey one step ahead
of you blackface already
already did it no you didn't have to do
that and they're like well i already did
so
and they're like you don't have it on
right now and they're like all right
well i'll take it off whatever dude what
would be the thing that you do if you
want to be present how would you
compromise yourself how would i
compromise myself yeah
besides a trip to puerto rico in the
near future
yeah i guess besides that that would be
compromising okay um
no that's a great question i don't know
i guess it's got to be bad right it's
got to be like compromise worthy death
maybe kill a guy yeah yeah i'd probably
be death
yeah yeah just a random person
no like somebody that was like a bad
business deal or something like that
because i would rather that obviously
i'm not gonna do anything to chicks
um and then what else is there
like i don't do anything like racist or
hateful but like people can justify
killing someone
like i feel like murder is is one of the
most justifiable things
what about an embarrassing one like the
trump getting peed on type [ __ ]
who's that embarrassing too
why is that embarrassing why do you find
that embarrassing i mean you know cold
rush is it was refreshing after a
freezing day walking around to get hot
piss
hot russian piss all over your body to
warm you up good point i wonder if he
fake not it on her oh 100 100 100 that's
how new yorkers do it bro
you think he was actually giving a nut
up
no way you can't give the nut up abroad
yo that's too risky
that's too risky he's gotta fake it
every time oh yeah i'm not abroad i
don't think i ever have enough no you
never i might have [ __ ] up a couple
you nutted abroad
[Applause]
you